first of all we are not worthy of you in
this look tonight this is you look
incredible
beautiful um i just it's been made by uh
ellie muddy oh i love it now did you
guys have to get did you get your
approval before she wore this tonight
yes you two look so beautiful
what are you gonna say i was just gonna
say i just wanna they wanted to thank
simons for their outfits yes
[Applause]
tonight
you guys just look so
incredible so excited that they're here
my whole family's here and it's really
just like a really touching moment it's
a historic moment to be the first and um
i'm just gonna i can't wait to have that
glass of wine at the end of the night
okay so i want to know how are you
feeling about the performance are you
excited are you feeling emotional what's
going through your head well i'm super
disciplined so i haven't i haven't had a
glass of wine or anything before the
show after the show
talk to me there
i love that it's all about the wine i
want to know
i want to know what kind of wine are you
drinking i usually love red wine ooh i'm
a pinot noir girl
that's amazing um you guys are here this
is so exciting did you guys all
coordinate the outfits because it looks
like you did
you know it was
what we felt in the moment yeah i mean
and what we felt best in love and um
we're just
just happy to just all be here together
i love birding this moment so listen you
know your mom's cool but does she hit
like a another level of cool being
inducted into the canadian music hall of
fame like do you know when she sings
you're like okay mom sing whenever you
want
yeah you never used it
oh my goodness do you ever get nervous
for your mom when she's performing
oh i'm not really i'm just know that
she's gonna kill it
i love it did you pay them to say that
not at all
that's so amazing um so this is exciting
for so many artists simulu is hosting
tonight he's our marvel superhero huge
fan yes we've met him backstage had a
great conversation
amazing okay so i gotta ask all of you
if you were to have a superhero power
what would it be
superhero power i would want to be
i would want to be like invisible so i
could just like walk through walls and
doors and like peek in and spy on people
listening on people's conversations i
like it okay what would your super power
be what she said i mean
i like that
maybe you just have the power to summon
anything
that's a powerful one listen such an
exciting night for you you look so
gorgeous